[Music]
hi everyone and welcome to lesson three
this lesson will be similar to the
previous lesson but going over how to
plot and customize
box plots another very common plot type
used in ecology when you want to
visualize the association
of a continuous variable between various
categorical groups
these are also called box and whisker
plots first we'll load the same data as
before
the plant growth data and just as a
quick reminder
the one column the weight column
represents the dried biomass weight
in grams of each plant and group
represents three different treatments
that were used when growing the plant
and these data include 30 different
samples
okay so let's go on and make our first
box plot and let's do that by comparing
the weight values between
each of these treatments and so what's
neat is that the regular plot function
will automatically create a box plot if
the x-axis
variable is categorical and so if we
look at the group variable in our data
set
plant growth
we can see that this is a categorical
factor variable
with the levels control treatment 1 and
treatment 2.
so if we do plot
weight
as a function of group
theta equals plant growth
and run that r will automatically create
a nice box plot showing weight as the
y-axis and these different groups
as the x-axis and there it is so this
isn't a statistics class
but here's a quick overview of the
different parts of the block box plot
for your reference so the dark line
within each of these groups
represents the median value the gray box
is the interquartile range of your data
of each of these categories so that
means between the 25th
and the 75th quartile so 50
of all of your data points lie within
this gray area then the whiskers or
these lines
mark the maximum and minimum range of
the data
excluding outliers the outliers are
calculated so like this point right here
is considered
technically considered an outlier is
calculated as
any points that are greater or less than
the interquartile range
times 1.5 so essentially it provides a
standardized method for labeling points
if they're very far from
all the other points but it's a bit more
of a conceptual
theoretical uh question as to whether
these are
actually treated as outliers or not but
this isn't a statistics course so i'm
not really going to go into that
but for now i'm just explaining what
these different aspects of the box plot
represent
so now as with the scatter plots we can
play around with these axes a bit
so let's copy and paste that here
and let's add in let's modify the x
and the y labels
so x lab let's do treatment
group y
lab equals dried biomass
weight in grams so if we run that there
we go
okay but the the labels for each
individual treatment group
are still not very clear and to change
those let's actually change the data
themselves to have category names that
are a bit clearer
and so we can look at that by using the
levels function
and plant growth
within groups so again this is our
vector of groups and it's a factor
variable because you can see that here
we have these three different levels
and the levels function just kind of
extracts those three levels so we can
look at them
control or ctrl trt1
and trt2 so we can replace those
with some names that are a little bit
more meaningful so let's say that we
know treatment 1 is low sunlight
and treatment 2 is high sunlight
or a lot of sunlight so we could maybe
rename these as
levels so actually we don't have to
rewrite this
so into so this function extracts the
levels
but we can modify those levels by
defining new levels right into this
function
like that so let's define the new level
names as
control
highlight
and low light
okay something like that maybe we'll add
a little dash here
great so now i ran that row and now
let's just take a look
at there you go
so see these different levels have been
renamed accordingly
so now if we run this same set of code
one more time
run it right here now you can see that
these labels have been
renamed accordingly so next let's
customize the design of the box plot a
bit more by changing the color of the
boxes as i mentioned in the previous
lesson you should always strive for
black and white or grayscale unless
color is
absolutely necessary for visualizing
your data and and that definitely
applies to this case
but i'm just going to show it to you
here how to modify the colors just for
completeness so let's just copy that
again
here and we will add in
simple argument of call
equals and again we can add in a custom
color
such as blue you can add hex code colors
this will take several different forms
of color values but we can also use
integer values that represent a series
of different built-in colors so in this
case let's do
call equals four and when we run that
we get this nice blue color that fills
in all the boxes
you can also remove the border around
the boxes using
box lty
and that just represents box line type
equals zero
so that removes this black border around
the boxes we can make the
whiskers instead of having them be
dotted we can make them solid
using the
whisk lty
equals one like that and then we can
also make all the lines just a bit
thicker
so we can do that using whisk lwd
line width equals let's say 1.5
and then the end this top is also called
the staple
so we can say staple line width
equals 1.5
so that just made the lines just a
little bit thicker kind of making it all
a little bit more visually appealing
and i kind of tend to prefer this type
of look for a bit
of a cleaner box plot all right so now
let's
change the orientation of the box plot
again let's
copy that over and what i mean by
orientation is just
add in this argument horizontal
equals true and that just turns
everything sideways in some cases box
plots for certain types of data or when
you have a lot of different categories
it becomes a little bit neater to have
the box plots go horizontally like that
so great that's it for this lesson so
far these lessons should
have given you everything you need for
creating the two most common types of
plots in ecology
using r's built-in plot function in
summary in this lesson we went over
building a box plot the using just the
simple plot
function and the only difference is that
the
data on the x-axis are now categorical
instead
of continuous we went over the different
parts of the box plot and what they
represent
and how to change the axis labels and
axis names on the box plot how to
customize the color and visual style of
the boxes and the whiskers
and finally how to turn the boxes on
their side and with that
i hope you enjoyed this lesson in the
next lesson i'm going to go over
a simple method for prototyping and
saving the plots that you make in
r